N
SOCIALIST AMERICANS HERE AT HOME
HAVE BIGGER FISH TO FRY.
IN JUST TWO YEARS THIS INAPT
ADMINISTRATION AND OF COURSE
THEIR CLIMATE CULT, THEY HAVE
NEARLY DESTROYED THE AMERICAN
DREAM FOR ALL OF US.
HERE WITH REACTION FORMER SENIOR
COUNSEL TO THE PRESIDENT, FORMER
WHITE HOUSE PHYSICIAN DR. RONNIE
JACKSON, KELLY AND WITH 39 DAYS
AWAY FROM ELECTION DAY,
JEN PSAKI IS RIGHT.
IF THIS ELECTION IS A REFERENDUM
ON JOE BIDEN, THE CLIMATE CULT
AND THEIR FAILED POLICIES AND
HOW THEY HAVE WRECKED ALL THE
PROGRESS THAT WE MADE IN THE
FOUR YEARS UNDER DONALD TRUMP,
THEN THEY LOSE.
IF IT'S ABOUT ALL THE OTHER
STUFF, THEY WON'T FARE MUCH
BETTER, WHICH WAY IS THE COUNTRY
GOING TO GO?
>> THIS IS THE MOST
UNCOMPLICATED STRAIGHTFORWARD
ISSUE SET OF EVER SEEN IN THREE
DECADES OF DOING THIS.
RISING COSTS, RISING CRIME WE
HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE CONCERNED
ABOUT EDUCATION.
PARENTS SAY THEY HAVE A
FUNDAMENTAL RIGHT TO SAY WHERE
THEIR CHILDREN GO TO SCHOOL AND
WHAT IS TAUGHT THERE.
WE SEE WHAT WE SEE ON TV EVERY
NIGHT, RUNS COUNTER TO WHAT THE
DEMOCRATS BEGINNING WITH
JOE BIDEN AND KAMALA HARRIS WANT
US TO BELIEVE, THEY WANT US TO
BELIEVE WHAT THEY SAY, NOT WHAT
WE SEE.
WE SEE WILD PEOPLE OUT OF
CONTROL ARBITRARILY COMMITTING
CRIMES.
WE SEE THE COST OF EVERYTHING
GOING UP AND OUT OF CONTROL, WE
SEE THE REPORT THAT ONE OF THE
FASTEST-GROWING NEW GROUPS OF
HOMELESS IN OUR COUNTRY ARE
SINGLE MOMS WHO HAVE A JOB.
THEY ACTUALLY HAVE A JOB BUT
THEY GET BEHIND IN THE RENT.
THIS IS JOE BIDEN'S AMERICA.
THE KEY TO REPUBLICANS DISK WE
CAN BUY WITH A FEW SEATS AND
MAYBE A 50/50 SENATE AND A 51-49
SENATE AND HAVING A MONSTER
NIGHT IS THIS.
HAVING AN AFFIRMATIVE POSITIVE
MESSAGE THAT'S DOABLE,
ACCESSIBLE, AND ACTIONABLE.
COMMITMENT TO AMERICA, NATION IT
IS SAFE AND ECONOMY THAT IS
STRONG, GOVERNMENT TO THIS
ACCOUNTABLE AND A FUTURE THAT IS
FREE.
NUMBER 2, TO YOUR POINT ABOUT A
BITE AND COME BIDEN, PELOSI,
HARRIS, AND THE REST.
AND PENNSYLVANIA JOHN FETTERMAN
HAS TO EAT AND OWN ALL OF HIS
OWN STATEMENTS.
HE IS PRO-CRIMINAL,
ANTI-FRACKING BUT HE HAS TO BE
SADDLED WITH THE BIDEN-HARRIS
ADMINISTRATION.
SAME THING WITH RAPHAEL WARNOCK,
IN NEVADA, HE HAS TO DO THAT
WITH THAT FEMALE DEMOCRATIC
SENATOR WHO HAS THREE NAMES AND
NO ACCOMPLISHMENTS.
PEOPLE HAVE TO BE HELD TO
ACCOUNT AS DEMOCRATS.
WHEN KAMALA HARRIS STOOD IN
NORTH KOREA LOOKING SO FOOLISH
AND EMBARRASSING THE ENTIRE
NATION OF FREE PEOPLE BUT AT THE
DMZ AND SHE SOUNDED LIKE SHE WAS
ON TMZ.
IT LOOKED LIKE A CARICATURE, ASK
MAGGIE HASSAN IF SHE'S
COMFORTABLE WITH THAT LEVEL OF
LEADERSHIP.
THE ABILITY TO MAKE EVERY
DEMOCRAT OUT THERE EAT AND OWN
THE FAILURES AND THE FLAILING OF
THIS ADMINISTRATION IS THE KEY
TO A MONSTER VICTORY IN A FEW
SHORT WEEKS.
>> Sean: BETWEEN KELLY ON AND
MYSELF WE HAVE SIX DECADES OF
EXPERIENCE THAT I AGREE WITH
HER.
THIS WILL BE THE BIGGEST CHOICE
ELECTION IN OUR LIFETIME, THIS
MATTERS.
WE CAN DEFINITELY POINT OUT ALL
OF THEIR FAILURES BUT I LIKE THE
COMMITMENTS WITH AMERICA BECAUSE
THEY ARE PLEDGING ENERGY
INDEPENDENCE, THEY ARE PLEDGING
TO CONTROL THE BORDERS.
THEY ARE PLEDGING TO BRING BACK
LAW AND ORDER AND THE SAFETY AND
SECURITY.
THEY ARE PLEDGING CHOICE IN
EDUCATION.
THEY ARE PLEDGING A BETTER
ECONOMY THAN THE INFLATION, THE
RECESSION THAT BIDEN GOT US IN.
THOSE PROMISES AND COMMITMENTS,
THE EITHER FOLLOW-THROUGH OR
THEY DON'T, IF THEY DON'T FOLLOW
THROUGH, THEY GET FIRED.
THOSE OF THE PRINCIPLES THAT
WILL BRING AMERICA BACK.
>> ABSOLUTELY, WE HAVE A LOT OF
WORK TO DO.
WE ARE GOING TO FULFILL THOSE
COMMITMENTS, WAIT AND SEE.
EVERYTHING JOE BIDEN TOUCHES
DOMESTICALLY AND
INTERNATIONALLY, KELLY AND IS
EXACTLY RIGHT.
IT GOES HORRIBLY WRONG.
THIS MAN IS GOING TO BE 80 YEARS
OLD NEXT MONTH AND HE LOOKS
ABSENTLY HORRIBLE, HE LOOKS LIKE
HE'S GOING TO FALL ASLEEP AT ANY
MINUTE WHEN HE SPEAKS.
HE SLURS HIS SPEECH, HE SHUFFLES
WHEN HE WALKS.
BLANK STARE, SHAKING HANDS WITH
PEOPLE WHO DON'T EXIST, HE'S
TALKING TO DEAD PEOPLE NOW.
THIS MAN IS INSPIRING OUR
ENEMIES, THE PEOPLE WHO ARE
WATCHING THIS MOST CLOSELY ARE
IRAN AND CHINA AND RUSSIA.
THEY ARE INSPIRED BY WHAT THEY
SEE BECAUSE THEY REALIZE WE DO
NOT HAVE COMPETENT LEADERSHIP IN
THIS COUNTRY, SOMETHING VERY BAD
IS GOING TO HAPPEN IN THE NEAR
FUTURE WITH THIS MAN AT THE
HELM.
THE PEOPLE WHO ARE ENABLING HIM
ARE GOING TO HAVE THE ANSWER TO
THIS TOO BECAUSE IT IS PAST TIME
FOR SOMEBODY IN HIS
ADMINISTRATION TO STEP UP TO THE
PLATE AND DO THE RIGHT THING AND
LET US KNOW WHAT'S GOING ON.
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT HAVE A
DUTY TO DO THAT.
HIS PHYSICIAN TO START WITH, HIS
CABINET MEMBERS, JILL BIDEN ALL
THE PEOPLE WHO SURROUND HIM, THE
CHIEF OF STAFF -- SUSAN RICE AND
EVERYBODY ELSE IN THE WEST WING.
THEY OWE US AN EXPLANATION OF
WHAT'S GOING ON WITH THIS MAN
AND WE NEED ANSWERS BECAUSE THIS
IS LEADING US DOWN A PATH OF
DESTRUCTION BOTH DOMESTICALLY
AND INTERNATIONALLY AND I THINK
SOMETHING BAD IS GOING TO HAPPEN
IN THE NEAR FUTURE BECAUSE WE DO
NOT HAVE LEADERSHIP IN THE
WHITE HOUSE.
>> Sean: I HAVE NO IDEA I
DON'T THINK ANYBODY CAN SAY WITH
ANY CERTAINTY